on today's menu we got an explanation
for cyberpunk 2077's lack of police
chases as well as an update on halo and
mass effect
so if you've played cyberpunk 2077 in
the past year then you may have realized
that outside of the scripted mission
sequences police never chase you in a
vehicle they also had a habit of
appearing out of thin air instead of
driving up to the scene of the crime
like in most open world games well now
2077's quest director pavel sasco spoke
about the missing feature during a
recent stream according to sasko there
wasn't enough time to make a police
chase system work before release that
mixed with technical limitations of the
engine led the team to eventually give
up on the feature and speaking of
missing features you might have also
noticed that night city's train system
didn't work however thanks to the magic
of mods now it does the cyberpunk 2077
metro system mod by neowize features 19
working stations and full integration
with the game's ui and controls and
players can switch between first and
third person views
over the weekend halo infinite had its
first big in-person professional
tournament and according to 343's
esports league tashi the event was the
most viewed halo esports event of all
time after just one day of competition
however no specific viewership numbers
were made available tashi also revealed
some competitors were using quote
development consoles due to the ongoing
semiconductor shortages on twitter tashi
said players in the open bracket will
play on series x development units which
are fundamentally identical and will run
in retail mode
in other halo news 343 industries is
aware of big team battle's matchmaking
issues and is reportedly a top priority
the issues involve players attempting to
match make into halo infinite's 12v12
multiplayer playlist frequently
receiving matchmaking errors and those
who do find a match having a high chance
of finding themselves with far fewer
teammates than normal in a forum post on
halo waypoint 343 confirms that it has
seen an increase in big team battle
matchmaking errors over the past few
days steps the team has already taken to
migrate the issue such as reducing sizes
to 10v10 and disabling the ability for
players to join in progress have not had
a meaningful impact and have been
removed 343 describes the problem as
complex because of this and the upcoming
holidays a patch to address the problem
likely won't come until 2022
so it appears the next mass effect game
will as rumored run on epic's unreal
engine bioware producer brennan holmes
recently tweeted about an open position
at the company for associate technical
director and the ideal candidate will
have experience with unreal engine 4 and
5. this doesn't flat out confirm that
the new mass effect game will run on
some form of the unreal engine however
reporter jeff grubb who was among the
first to report the next mass effect
will use the unreal engine followed up
to say that this is indeed the case and
that it's unreal engine 5 specifically
and if jeff grubb is right then that
means we might be able to steer clear of
some of the frostbite engine glitches
that made andromeda a comedy so what's
your favorite mass effect game let me
know in the comments below
later
[Music]